>> RAMSDALE: Hello. Hi, everybody. I want
to thank you for coming out. This is the GWT
Fireside Chat and what I want to do is take
an hour, and I think you've been through some
of these. We're going to do a little bit of
talking about ourselves but really open this
us up to Q&A. This is your opportunity as
developers to ask our developers, us, what
we've been up to, where we're going, and maybe
some of the ins and the outs of the features
that we've been introducing with 2.0 and,
as of yesterday, our release of our alpha
version 2.1. So let me take a second to introduce
the panel up here. My name is Chris Ramsdale.
This is Kathrin Probst. This is Amit Manjhi,
Bob Vawter, Jaime Yap, and Eric Ayers. And
we all work on GWT in different aspects. And
most of us are in the Atlanta office; some
of us are in the actual San Francisco office.
And if we're lucky, we might have a few others
come in as Joel and Ray were wrapping up the
GWT UI Overhaul talk in one of the other rooms.
So with that said, what we want to do is maybe
give a little bit of the overview on what
we've been working on since our 2.0 released
back in December leading up to I/O and 2.1
release we have. So to put you guys on the
spot, ha-ha, enjoy this, maybe we'll kind
of work our way down and I thought we could
talk with about--since we have Kathrin and
Amit sitting right here, maybe give us an
idea of where we've been with the AJAX crawl
and how we're trying to make GWT and other
applications crawlable by search engines,
not just Google but eventually Microsoft and
Yahoo as well. So Kathrin?
>> PROBST: Right, so as all of you who are
probably good developers know AJAX crawlability
has been traditionally a big problem in that
crawlers don't normally see the content that's
dynamically produced on the website on your
page. So we have put together a convention
between participating websites and the crawler.
This is now implemented in live in the Google
crawler, not yet in other crawlers, but it
is live in the Google crawler. And what it
essentially is is a mapping between your normal
URLs that you would have including with your
hash fragments and a different type of URL
that has the token-escape-fragment in it.
What happens is that, essentially, the crawler
will query from you, from your site, URLs
that have this escape fragment token in it
and it is the web server's responsibility
to essentially return an HTML snapshot that
represents the content that the site wants
in the crawler index so that it is searchable
and served up by in the Google search results.
Now, the URLs that show up in the Google search
results are actually your normal URLs that
you use with C on the page. There is--the
spec is out there. It's under code.google.com/web/ajaxcrawling.
For GWT, in particular, what we recommend
in order to get the HTML snapshot is a headless
browser. There is various tools out there,
the one that we've been working on the most;
in particular, Amit and me, it's HtmlUnit.
It's a free tool that you can download. We
have put some improvements in it. And especially
Amit has worked very hard on getting this
pushed out to HtmlUnit and also on getting
it to work on App Engine. So, maybe you want
to talk.
>> MANJHI: All right. So one of the things
we are doing with HtmlUnit is patching HtmlUnit
so that it can work on App Engine. In particular,
App Engine has limitations that you can have
only a single thread. It also has some limitations
on some Java classes that you can use. So,
the patch is uploaded on a public, like the
HtmlUnit issue tracker, it is still not in
HtmlUnit but hopefully within the next few
weeks HtmlUnit 2.8 will have this patch included.
But if you want to try it out and have your
ServLix give out a version that is crawlable.
You can use HtmlUnit on your website and include
the patch.
>> PROBST: And people have done that also
with the patch already.
>> MANJHI: Yes, people have already done that
successfully with their patch. And we also
have a demo website that is included in the
issue tracker where you can give it to AJAX;
URL to AJAX page and it will show you--it
will run an HtmlUnit and it will show you
the DOM of the page. So it will essentially
run the JavaScript and then show you the DOM.
>> RAMSDALE: Yeah, and we'll make sure that
the--of the sites that they're referencing,
as well as the projects, we can easily toss
into the live wave, be it the one you're viewing
over here, the one that John is actually taking
notes on, which by the way, if anybody has
or is viewing, we strongly suggest that comments
that you have going on and side conversations,
right now, please put those on wave. They've
been very valuable especially if you saw,
there is quite a lengthy conversation with
Kelly's Measure in Milliseconds yesterday,
riding through some really media information
that went back and forth both from developers
like yourself and developers that are working
on the Speed Tracer product which we have
two of them down here. We'll talk about that
in a second. So I encourage you to check out
wave; it's great. And John will help guide
you through it. Since we got Bob up here,
I was going to suggest maybe if you wanted
to give a kind of recap of where we are with
GWT RPC, deRPC. But feel free to chime in
on anything else that you've been focused
on in the past few months.
>> VAWTER: Yeah. So we did launch--we did
put the deRPC code base out there which is
kind of--you know, if we were going to re-implement
the GWT RPC stack, for those of you not familiar
with it, GWT RPC provides you with an RPC
system that is designed to transport, you
know, Java objects and all their polymorphic
goodness across the wire. It's a very easy
way to get started with an RPC system. You
don't really have to sit down and think about,
okay, I need to build a protocol and, you
know, how am I going to do, you know, encapsulation
on the, encapsulation escaping, framing, all
that kind of stuff that, you know, goes on
into the level stuff. Basically, just think
about what is the service that I want my server
to be able to provide to my client? And you
just set that up in terms of the asynchronous
interface using your, you know, DTL objects,
you know, vanilla beans kind of stuff. And
we have shipped sort of a preview release
of that in GWT 2.0, the deRPC system which
provides a number of performance and improvements
with that. There have been a lot of other
discussions around formalizing license support
for Google's Protocol Buffers in GWT which
do require sort of a lower-level thought process
about message structure and stuff like that,
but could provide even more performance gains
if you're willing to do a little bit more
work on the front end. We've made a number
of, you know, compiler and hosting load improvements
be--after the 2.0 timeframe. Soft permutations
are coming down the wire which, if you're
familiar with GWT's deferred binding system
sort of having, you know, the entire Cartesian
product to value your permutation values produced;
you can take certain axis or values and collapse
them. So if you want to add, you know, so,
right now, you can target Safari. And that
includes, you know, like your mobile browsers,
the mobile iPhone, the Android browser. But
you could add additional user agent values
and collapse them so they result in the same
permutation objects. Those little tiny variations
don't result in all the cost of another hard
permutation. And hosted mode performance continuous
to be a huge, huge focus area. And I think
Scott and Keith are, you know, chained to
their desk in Atlanta right now; they've been
forced to make it faster.
>> RAMSDALE: Yeah and to give you a quick
idea, I think these are some rough figures
and I don't know if you were in the conversation.
But we were talking to Adam from the wave
team and much like Edwards; they're at a very
high number of permutations right now. I actually
think, for some reason, they jumped from 256
to 512. But, that aside, he has said with
his initial research into it that they could
effectively cut out at least half the permutations
which is--and really, what you're doing, I
think, and Bob can correct me but you're--aren't
you collapsing down all of the permutations
that really shares in the same characteristics?
>> VAWTER: Yeah, that's right. What we're
giving you is not something that you should
think about when you first come out to write
your application. This is one of those things
that is used as an optimization after you've
built your app the way you want to build it
in the first place. We're giving these final-grain
controls. And, you know, when you add a new
deferred binding property and a new value
to that, basically, you are just expanding
the size of the Cartesian product of all of
the deferred binding property values. So if
you add one more property that's like a Boolean's
true/false, you're going to double the number
of cache.js or cache@html files that you double.
And with the work with conditional deferred
binding properties and soft property values,
what that gives you is the ability to use
deferred binding as much as you want without
suffering additional compiled time and deployment
cost in terms of more files. So you can add,
you can use deferred binding for small little
switches in your App or you might use a--where
if statements are kind of ugly just because
you haven't sprinkled all throughout the code.
>> RAMSDALE: Like I said Jaime and Eric who
are part of the Speed Tracer team and--by
the show of hands, how many people know what
Speed Tracer is?
>> YAP: Awesome.
>> RAMSDALE: Fantastic, so we don't have to
cover that. Get in to the good stuff.
>> YAP: So, yeah, so hopefully, you guys saw
the "Measure in Milliseconds Redux" talk yesterday.
Show of hands, who saw that talk? All right.
Those who didn't see should watch it on YouTube;
it's very good. So when we first launched
Speed Tracer, we kind of gave new insight
into what was happening on the client. We
also included a network view which is very
similar to other network waterfall views that
you see in tools like Firebug. And obviously
web application performance is heavily influenced
by the things happening on the server. So
the problem with traditional network waterfall
views is that they give you time ranges and
you can see payloads and you can see headers,
but the timings are essentially, you know,
a black box; you don't know what happened
on the server. So usually, you have to use
some server-side tooling to dig in deeper.
And it gets kind of hard to correlate a specific
RPC with a specific action on the server.
So, we thought it'd be a great idea if in
Speed Tracer, we could kind of get an end-to-end
performance picture. So if you saw in the
keynote in Kelly's talk we demoed server side
traces on App Engine and Spring Insight. So
that's new with Speed Tracer so...
>> RAMSDALE: And Spring Insight, for anybody
that didn't catch it in the keynote is they
have--Spring Insight is more like a container
that runs with your App. And so the Spring
Source community, VMware/SpringSource, they
have a version; it's called tc Server. It's
really just their version of Tomcat that's
running with instrumentation in it. And so
what they're doing is it's very analogous
to what App stats is doing for App Engine
now where they're collecting this data that
Jaime is talking about. And what we're doing
is, again, just feeding off that JSON payload
that they spit out. And it's kind of nice
because I believe that there is some parallels
between the two systems. While they are offering
up different data, we get more on App Engine
than we do on tc Server right now or via Insight.
>> YAP: So, one of the nice properties for
things happening on the single thread, I guess,
is that you can kind of model the things that
you want to instrument in this nice little
JSON tree structure. So it's the same, very
similar JSON structure to what we used to
represent things happening on the UI thread
in our sluggishness graph. So it kind of--there's
no extra burden. You don't have to learn how
to visualize--how to understand a new visualization.
It's the same visualization because it's the
same kind of data. So--but they, yes, they
instrument different things on App Engine
versus Spring Insight.
>> RAMSDALE: But, right, they don't have a
memcache for example.
>> YAP: Yeah.
>> RAMSDALE: So, Eric, do you want to talk
about some of the kind of headless Speed Tracer
work that you've been doing and where do you
think that's going?
>> AYERS: Sure, Chris. So the Speed Tracer
is really eye-catching because it has all
this nice user interface and graphs and the
ability to share your Speed Tracers with everyone.
And I've been working on a part of Speed Tracer
that takes all that away. Instead of a nice
user interface, it has no user interface at
all. And what it's useful for is to take that
data that come out of Speed Tracer and then
extend it on to a third-party application.
And our sort of target for this has been for
keeping track of latency so you can watch
over time and see whether you have any latency
regressions. Another thing that I've worked
on in the past is the Hintlet Engine, we call
it, that's built in to Speed Tracer which
we have codes that you can extend and run
analysis within Speed Tracer. But this headless
extension, you know, it gathers up the data
during the browsing session or during a unit
test and sends it off. And then you could
use that same data to write your own analysis,
maybe analysis over many traces or using some
more complex tools that you might want to
use within, say, a JavaScript environment
like inside the browser. Another thing I've
been working on besides Speed Tracer is Google
API library for GWT. And I've been working
on this for several years and has Bob. Bob
wrote the gadget and search bindings. And
I've been maintaining them and we just, in
time for GWT 2.1, have released the GWT 2.0
integration of the Google API libraries; that
was just last week. And these libraries include
things like the chart tools, maps, translations,
and so on. It just provides an easy-to-use
wrapper on top of the JavaScript APIs that
are already out there for JavaScript authors.
And we'll be releasing the maps, a part of
that very soon in the next week or so. And
then, I've been working with an intern who's
going to be focusing on updating gadgets and
integrating OpenSocial.
>> RAMSDALE: Great. So that's kind of a snapshot
of what we've been up to right now. And I
see that we have a dory page up but it looks
a little bit odd to tell you the truth. Can
everybody see the wave that's going on right
now? So I think what we'll do is instead,
unless somebody can explain why we're getting
questions about Sony Ericsson, Ken, we'll
let you hope up and just ask questions and
we'll field them. Mind you, we're actually
missing our two UI guys that were in a talk,
so Ray and Joel; but if we get some UI questions,
we can always pull in John, right, and talk.
So, yeah, feel free to open up the questions
and we'll take them.
>> Okay. Are we ready?
>> YAP: Yes.
>> RAMSDALE: Okay, go ahead.
>> MIKE: Hi, I'm Mike. So I recently--I wanted
to use a Dojo library. And so for every object
in Dojo that I want use, I've been sub-classing
JavaScript object which works out really great.
It's a very nice thin layer and it kind of
does all the things that it seems to have
been envisioned to do. One complication though,
the resulting classes, the sub-classes of
JavaScript object don't provide a very good
API for the rest of your code since instance
methods have to be final and you can have
constructors and things like that. So, my
sort of very generalized approach to dealing
with that has been to create--you know, so
I have this sort of tree of JavaScript object
sub-classes and I then have another tree of
JavaScript object delegate classes. Each of
those has a JavaScript object, sub-classes,
and member and then it provides a much better
API for, you know, the code that it tends
to work with this objects. So it has been
nice. But as you can probably imagine that
there's some intermediate objects contractions
that happens as a result of that. And in fact,
it actually--once you get into the nitty-gritty,
you start to notice that, sometimes, a simple
method cost, simple gather on an object involves
an object contraction as a result of that.
The only little bit of information I've been
able to find on the Internet about this is,
I guess, there is an annotation called SingleJsoImpl.
They don't know much about how that really
helps with the issue that I just described.
So any--take it away.
>> VAWTER: The--so there's actually not an
annotation anymore. The original--in the original
design doc, we were going to have this--have
annotations. So--but the name SingleJsoImpl
is a terrible name but it's the one that stuck
to describe this concept. The idea behind
this is that JavaScript objects can implement
interfaces that declare methods. The caveat
is that you cannot do polymorphic method dispatch
on a JavaScript object sub-class because there's
no Java type information associated with that
underlying JSO. We assumed that it's coming
from some external library and we can't just
like jam a type ID field on there because
that might break the integration gates. So
if you want a JavaScript object to be able
to implement and interface with a method,
any of these methods defined in and interfaced
must be implemented by, at most, one Java
method that is declared within a JavaScript
object. So you got that one-to-one mapping
at runtime when you compile.
>> So that doesn't--so it sounds like that's
not actually the solution to the problem.
>> VAWTER: Well, it can be because--so the
wave guys had an issue which is why we built
single-JSO-implement in the first place, that
all of their wire protocol is basically very
lightweight protobuffer style and they don't
want their--they don't want all the other
classes in their system to have to, you know,
take a sub-type of JSO. They want it to pass
an interface because it also helps with testing.
So if you want to provide a Java-like API,
there's really nothing you can do beyond having
this Java facade objects for things like,
you know, instanceof and, you know, type-specific
two-string methods. You know, if you are providing
your users with a use case where you need
Java polymorphic type behavior, you're stuck
with that. Otherwise, we'd have to go and,
you know, jam fields and what-not onto your
underlying JSOs and then possibly break them.
>> I see. One more quick question about the
sub-class in JavaScript object and particularly
using JavaScript objects in the wild, I still
need to get around the resource button line
a little bit. So like the Dojo library itself,
could that be a resource which is bundled?
>> VAWTER: Yes.
>> Okay.
>> VAWTER: The client bundle system is arbitrarily
extensible.
>> Yes.
>> VAWTER: All of the built-in types use the
extension API. So if you want to create a
new resource type, call it, you know, JavaScript
resource or whatever, it's basically, you
declare an interface which is a sub-type of
resource prototype. It has an annotation at
resource generator that then points to and
implement a runtime--a compile-time called
back class that basically just says, okay,
you know, implement, you know, give me the
text that implements this method and then
you do whatever you want to do there.
>> Okay. Do you think...
>> VAWTER: If you want to write JS resource,
it's just done. You can also, as a really,
really quick hack, use text resource.
>> RYAN: And for that matter, you can imitate
text resource, copy and paste it as a starting
point when you're writing your own resource
type.
>> Hello. Hey, thanks for having us here and
thanks for supporting GWT and continuing to
develop it. The question I have for you is
a support question. Looking for an alternative
to the forums as far as a way to get support
for questions, I'm wondering about if you
guys have considered like using the Stack
Overflow model like the Android guys have
used and potentially offering like an office
hours.
>> RAMSDALE: Yes, so I'll take that. It's
quite funny actually because I've had an email
that I was going to craft up to GWT contrib
and the main GWT group twice, actually, where
I was going to say, you know what, let's try
something better and let's actually move over
to Stack Overflow. And the reason we didn't
do that yet and pulled the trigger is because
there are some changes that are being made
to Google groups, from a group out in Boulder
and a few others that look promising both
from a backend and a front-end perspective.
We're pretty transparent around here so we're
a little skeptical as well, but they're, you
know, they're really trying hard. So I've
held off on that. That said, there's nothing
to stop everybody from going ahead and creating
their own group over there. I mean, I've watched
it for awhile and I've seen that the number
of questions that are tagged with G-W-T or
GWT have continued to grow. And Android has
had a lot of success; in fact, they have moved
over more of their mainline developers to
Stack Overflow and they've seen the groups
traffic go down and the Stack Overflow traffic
go up. Let's be honest, Stack Overflow is,
is great only because of the UI because I
think the developer community behind Stack
Overflow is just a little different. There's
different characteristics. So I encourage
everybody, you know, we're not going to try
to hold you in to using Google groups just
because we're Google Web Toolkit. Try out
Stack Overflow if you like it. Bring more
over, you know. And then if we decide to make
a move, a strategic move from a Google position,
I guess, we'll let everybody know. But we're
not going to stop you from creating your own
community in Stack Overflow.
>> VAWTER: Yeah, there is also...
>> Will you folks look at it? I mean do you
folks monitor that group, the GWT group?
>> RAMSDALE: With Stack Overflow?
>> Yeah.
>> RAMSDALE: Not actively right now. We watch
the traffic on Google groups to the most extent.
I mean, we want to grow a community that's
self-sufficient. And when there's actual burning
fires and problems, we help out. Obviously,
in the time of release via the GWT 2.1 Milestone
release, when there are some issues, we see
it, we address it, and move on. But we really
want to have a self-sustaining developer community.
>> VAWTER: Yeah, if you like IRC, irc.reno.net
channel GWT.
>> RAMSDALE: Say that one more time?
>> VAWTER: Irc.reno.net channel GWT.
>> RAMSDALE: Okay, there you go.
>> VAWTER: Mostly external developers but
I and a couple of the other GWT developers
hang out on there and field questions and
pique ideas around it.
>> RAMSDALE: Real quickly, and speaking on
the topic of support too, don't forget that
there are office hours that we're holding
up on the third floor. Jason Parekh and Fred
Sauer who I believe some of you actually might
know are going to be up there from 12 until
5:30 taking any questions you have. So, again,
also if we don't get through all these today
or this afternoon, feel free to jump up there.
>> Okay. So my question is what are your plans
to keep GWT up-to-date with all the new features
and capabilities that come along with HTML5;
specifically, canvass, lay out, SVG, and eventually
WebGL, things like that. Will there be a native
support for some of these things or are we
going to be needing to use the native methods
for all--for the new features of HTML5?
>> YAP: So, I guess, I can take part of that.
So Speed Tracer has a bunch of overlay types
to wrap some HTML5 functionality. And I think
we are definitely planning to make that first-order
priority for GWT. So, yes. That's to answer
your question that that is definitely on our
road map fairly soon so...
>> RAMSDALE: Yes, I mean, to think that we
could, to think that we can move on evolving
GWT without adopting HTML5 would be incorrect.
Stacking it against the things that we want
to do to help developers out in terms of speed,
size, sexier widgets, whatever it may be,
you know, that's the only problem. It's not
a huge team so we've got to plan our priorities
straight but we know that, like Jaime said,
not making HTML5 a first-class citizen would
probably be a mistake.
>> Okay.
>> RAMSDALE: Yeah.
>> Another quick question, what are your thoughts
on combining the power of GWT with the power
of say library like jQuery or Dojo and using
them in unison with each other rather than
one or the other?
>> YAP: Have you seen GQuery?
>> I have but it's...
>> YAP: It's pretty much a rewrite of jQuery
and GWT. Ray Cromwell, who's not here right
now but, if you see him around the floor,
you can talk to him about it. It's actually
really cool and he has some demos on the GQuery
code site page that shows you what it can
do. So, it takes a jQuery-style programming
model and gets all the benefits of the GWT
compiler to make it really fast. So, yeah,
it exists.
>> Cool. Thank you.
>> RAMSDALE: By the way, I think that you
can catch--Joel, and Ray, and Stefan are doing
the HTML5 plus GWT Talk right after this,
I believe.
>> YAP: Okay.
>> RAMSDALE: It's shortly thereafter. It's
today where they're going to be doing some
pretty cool stuff. Not only can you see what
we're experimenting with HTML5 and driving
it to the--really pushing the envelope; you
can also catch Ray Cromwell after this talk
if you want to discuss with him GQuery versus
jQuery and...
>> YAP: Yeah, I think it's called GWT Query
actually. It's GQuery.
>> PROBST: It's GQuery.
>> YAP: Okay, sorry.
>> RAMSDALE: Next?
>> Hi, I have a question about the performance.
We had--we use a GXT and a GWT to build a
real-time device control application like
every 15 milliseconds, there will be a new
item to deliver to the browser. But what we
found is it delivers to the browser site to
upgrade the graphics and GWT. What we found
is that the CPU and the memory usage of the
browser gets really high and it becomes not
a responsible-- responsive. If we slow down
to like 300 milliseconds to--or half a second
to do a batch processing, you'll get really,
you know, the performance is really good.
So is there any tip that you could provide,
you know, on those kind of real-time application
development?
>> RAMSDALE: I think we had a little issue
here. So you're using GXT and you're having
performance issues which we know...
>> Yes. We have to slow down our UI upgrade,
you know, update, you know, ratio. We cannot
update the UI every like a 15 milliseconds.
We have to slow down to like 200 or 300 milliseconds
to do a batch processing.
>> YAP: So, okay, I think that Ray--maybe
you want to take this one. But it seems like
your UI performance issues maybe limited to
the fact that you're using ExtGWT. But did
you ever...
>> RAMSDALE: GXT.
>> YAP: GXT. And if you take a look at Ray's
talk and Joel's talk that they just gave before,
what is it called, Ray?
>> RAMSDALE: GWT UI overhaul.
>> YAP: GWT UI overhaul, there's some new
widgets and some new ways of building your
data-backed UIs that should address it.
>> RAMSDALE: Well, and ultimately, though,
I mean you're using--so let's back up for
just a second. So what happens when you actually
update every 15 milliseconds versus every
300 milliseconds from a high level? Like,
does the UI just not update?
>> High-level library lets you see, you know,
it's very slow and not updated. You can see
the CPU usage...
>> Yeah.
>> ... the varied consumption because it's
like...
>> VAWTER: That is--that is a style of layout
that does much of your layout on the page
having to run JavaScript. So every time you
update the DOM, it has to drive a bunch of
JavaScript in order to refill the page, put
things where they need to go. And that's ultimately
much, much slower than relying on a rendering
model that utilizes the fast C code, you know,
that's built in to the browser to do layout
in C rather than layout in JavaScript. So,
your choice of UI Library--you know, I'm not
sure what your motivations are but you certainly
make a tradeoff whenever you're actually relying
on JavaScript to put things on the page. That's
going to make it slow. I suspect, if you put--if
you run your application Speed Tracer and
take a look at where the time is going, that
would be very illuminating.
>> All right. Thank you.
>> Something that has been really frustrating
for me has been date manipulations on the
clients' side. Is there anything, a roadmap
or a solution for good like Calendar-style
date manipulations on the client?
>> RAMSDALE: So I think the cross-talk here
tells you that there's--there's not a distinct
effort going on right now to make it better.
And I would venture to say that John Tamplin
is the guy that would--we want to be talking
to about that. He's not here.
>> VAWTER: Yeah, let's--let's volunteer John
to do some work.
>> RAMSDALE: Sounds good. I like it. But,
honestly, if you--so that would be--have you
tried posting either on GWT contributors or
the main GWT group to get some feedback from
anybody, the community or us, to make it better?
>> No, I just kind of searched around, trying
to find, you know, known solutions but we
kind of ended up rolling our own and converting
JodaTime's API to--you know, we kind of hacked
that up and made it work on the client which
isn't an ideal solutions because you'll lose
a lot and it's not--it's not complete is what
ends up happening but...
>> ARMSDALE: Okay.
>> ... you have that working.
>> RYAN: Similar things have gone on inside
of Google with teams that have built on partial
emulations of JodaTime for themselves. It's--I
don't think they've gotten anywhere farther
than where you've gotten, so we don't have
better advice, I don't think.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> We've been building applications with the
UI Binder and MPP Framework and Gin, and have
noticed that that, you know, there's been
a little bit of struggle to get that all kind
of tied together. And it seems like an opportunity
with 2.1 and the new MPP Framework to bring
those together, a little bit better. Is that
something you're addressing?
>> RYAN: It does seem like that, doesn't it?
We won't address that directly in the 2.1
timeframe. We are in close--we're good friends
with the Gin Team and big fans of it. And,
clearly, we need to get the things closer
together. But for the moment, you're on your
own there. Some of the features on UI Binder
were added to make stuff like Gin integration
possible so the UI field provided equals-true
attribute; in particular, UI Factors and so
on. But, you know, we don't have immediate
stuff. But we think about it a lot.
>> Thanks.
>> All right, Michael and I both work on holidayinn.com
website. We have a couple SCO-related questions.
One is surround the HtmlUnit and I believe
it was touched on a minute ago about a patch
that was out there for HtmlUnit. We were having
deadlock issues with our HtmlUnit and we got
the patch that fixed our deadlock issue. However,
we now noticed it seems slower and a lot of
threads are being utilized. A lot more threads
are being utilized than we used to. So is
there--is single threaded the way to go or
will there eventually be another patch that
would give us back to multi-threading that?
>> MANJHI: So JavaScript is inherently single-threaded.
So HtmlUnit's initial choice of using more
than one JavaScript thread was hard and unfortunate.
So they had like all kinds of synchronization
code in there so that they wanted to force
use of multiple threads and still force it
under the single GS margin. So, intuitively,
like once you--once you move from, like, multi-threaded
to like single-threaded, there would be some
things which would be like serials. So, intuitively,
there would be some--some speed-up lost but
you shouldn't be seeing much.
>> So maybe a better solution for us would
be the cache to the content?
>> PROBST: Right.
>> MANJHI: Right.
>> PROBST: So one of the things that you may
want to think about is how often to cache
your content and that really depends on how
often, you know, your content changes on the
page, right? And you probably also have a
pretty good idea from the escape fragment
URL that your Web server gets hit with how
often Google comes around, right?
>> Yeah.
>> PROBST: So you don't have to constantly
have it running.
>> Right. Okay, the second question with Michael.
>> Yeah, still same thing for the ISO. And
we utilized HtmlUnit and we found out escape
fragment carry the index by Google. So I put
on in the robust.txt to blog it. And, currently,
the assist on our ranking is sort of used.
So I want to say, is that right a way to do
or not? Because if I don't put on the robust.txt
in the carry index, so a user potentially
clicks that link--so if I put on that one,
it may affect the ranking. Is that clear?
>> MANJHI: I guess the--how the ordering in
robust.txt affects ranking. That is some...
>> It's a matter of that escape fragment,
we wanted to do exclude that.
>> MANJHI: Yeah.
>> So--because we don't our public to hit
this with that.
>> PROBST: Right.
>> Right. So, we're wondering what's the best
practice around that.
>> PROBST: I see what you're saying. So you
want to put something in robust.txt that says
to other people other than Google not to hit
it.
>> Right, on index, yes.
>> PROBST: Well, okay. So there--there has
recently been an update--wow.
>> VAWTER: Yeah, robust.txt does support crawler
agent filter blogs. Is that--does that give
you any leeway?
>> No, that was the same thing, yeah, group,
to escape, to remove all those blank GWT escape
fragment.
>> VAWTER: Yeah, and I guess the other thing
you could is you could look at, you know,
you can look at--you can do user agent filtering
on your server and just run a really quick
pass as a filter to say if it's not Googlebot,
just--or don't return anything or strip out
the hash tags you don't want.
>> Okay.
>> Hi, were the data presentation widgets
that you talked about in the keynote in the
M1 release, do you know?
>> RYAN: Yes, they are.
>> What are they called or how do we find
them?
>> RYAN: Look for cell list--list view. It's
the general interface. Look for cell list
view...
>> Okay.
>> RYAN: ... with the main notation and you'll
find everything in the summary.
>> Hi, we're an open source project for universities.
And our particular--we've chosen GWT as a
presentation tier for our architecture. Our
particular design challenge and we've been
working with GWT since 1.4 then recently 1.64,
now up to 2. Our design challenge is that
we have to make this open source framework
customizable and extensible for the schools
that will go and adopt this but they don't
have hard core GWT experience and they probably
won't be able to afford to buy it. So, we're
tasked with trying to use the benefits to
the GWT framework but make it extensible and
usable for those folks that can customize
it for their own needs. And we've been--we've
been pursuing a number of different MVC frameworks
from before GWT2. We're now looking at whether
UI Binder and framework of widgets is the
right way to go. And we're actually struggling
for, I guess, support and advice on the direction
we should take.
>> VAWTER: I mean what, you know, when you're
saying extension model, what kinds of scenarios
are you trying to support?
>> Different layouts; so easy layout construction
and also labels as internationalization as
well. So one school might refer to a course
as a course one or, you know, or student,
so they have different taxonomy models across
the--across the...
>> RYAN: Are you trying to let your users
provide the layout...
>> Yes.
>> RYAN: ...without having to know about GWT?
>> Correct.
>> Well.
>> VAWTER: It sounds so--it sounds like we
need to build server bundle finally. So, here's
a crazy idea that might work. If you can allow
your--if you want to give your users a sort
of, you know, give us a chunk of text, you
know, that describes your layout or whatever;
one thing that you might look at doing is
extending client bundle with custom resource
types that will process the, you know, the
user's, you know, mysite.xml file.
>> Right.
>> VAWTER: And return, you know, data to your--to
your application's layout system that will
then say, "Okay, you know, actually put this
widget here, put this widget there." You know,
take advantage of Joel's layout system. And
that might be a starting point, if you then
need to go on and allow the user to provide
additional code that runs in the application,
probably your best bet for approachability
is to--is to use something like GWT exporter
to give them a JavaScript API that they can--that
they can then work with. The GWT compiler
does--the architecture right now doesn't support
sort of pulling in additional Java modules...
>> Right.
>> VAWTER: ... at runtime, although, certainly
the GWT compiler is easy enough to use as
a tool as part of something else so you could
build a compilation server that for, you know,
so and so university, when a request comes
in, they could compile a module on the fly
that wouldn't be all that hard to architect;
you just want to take a look at the come Google
GWT dev compiler or pre-compiled perm and
links data.
>> Yeah, it's something we're looking at,
yeah.
>> VAWTER: Yeah, that's certainly an approach
that can give you some leverage there.
>> Okay. And just last question, and you mentioned
the IRC chat, is that something that you guys
listen in on, the IRC chat?
>> VAWTER: Yeah, the IRC channel? Yeah, I
usually hang out there.
>> Yeah.
>> VAWTER: Some of the other guys hang out
there too on occasion.
>> Okay. Great, thank you.
>> I have a couple of questions. So my company,
Numerad, we're big fans of Google collections
and extension to Java util. It looks like
in--from the source, there were--there was
kind of an intention to make that usable in
GWT client. Is that working now on the latest
release? I had some issues making some of
those classes available on the client.
>> RYAN: I should know the answer to that.
I don't quite. And, particularly, I'm not
sure what the state is of the open source
version of it versus those internal...
>> Okay.
>> RYAN: I know, there's a definite intention
to get it all working without having to think
about it. It's not something that we're driving.
It's something that the Guava guys keep going.
>> Okay.
>> RYAN: Yeah, I don't have a better answer
for you than that.
>> Okay. So there's no roadmap for when that
support might be available? I think what we've
ended up doing is just rolling around classes
based on the source.
>> RYAN: There's no roadmap on our side; although,
there's discussion about it a lot. I think
on the Guava side, there might be more concrete
plans so if you want to follow-up there. I
think another one use the stack overflow to
keep it in the community.
>> Okay, okay.
>> PROBST: Maybe one more thing to note is
that we're separately also working on lightweight
collections for GWT. I mean, that's something
you may--before you hand-roll your own, it's
something--you definitely want to look into
it. There's, you know, commits going into
trunk right now.
>> Okay.
>> PROBST: And, you know, at least be partially
part of 2.1 if not fully--I don't know.
>> RYAN: Yeah, the lightweight collections
as they have been implemented to date are
in the 2.1 snapshot. They have--they're kind
of almost an opposite goal of the collections
though where people who are in memory-tight
situations will often wind up doing is they
stay away from the GRE collection classes
and they'll roll their own. They can work
on top of the JSOs and so on that cut down
their code weight. As soon as you use the
GWT widget, the first thing that you pull
in is a good chunk of the JRE and, you do,
part of the reason that you do that is because
we use the standard Java collections. So,
we're putting together a more minimal collection
API that can work entirely as overweight types.
But as soon as you want to use something like
that, the Google collection classes, they're
going to be back into bridging into Java world
and so there'll be tensions.
>> Okay, all right, I'll take a look. Then
the other question was Sonar application;
we're interested in providing stable URLs
that, you know, so that you can link to a
place and a state, a particular part of that
application? I think you talked a little bit
about AJAX Crawler and using--being able to
look up or use the fragment identifier for...
>> PROBST: Right, so part of the spec for
the AJAX crawlability is to allow AJAX applications
to still have stable URLs with half fragments,
and also prospect these hash fragments are
not sent to the server as part of an HTTP
request, that's why there is a mapping between,
you know, hash fragment URLs and the escape
fragment URLs that essentially move the hash
fragment to be part of the query parameters.
So, essentially, there is this back and forth
mapping between, you know, what you have and
then what the Google Crawler actually requests
from your site. You will, you know, map it
back and return the content for the hash fragment
URL. And that's what actually gets indexed.
So in other words, this whole mapping back
and forth should not be visible to your users
at all, ever. Your users will always see the
hash fragment URL as they interact with the
site. It will be, you know, you can link to
it, you know, you can, you know, do all the
things you normally do and they will also
show up in search results. And, you know,
they will usually click on it and get to your
site, so you will--this is fully supported.
>> So is there a pattern you guys recommend
for specifying a location in a fragment identifier
and state or query parameters that you want
to pass...
>> PROBST: I'm sorry, is there a what?
>> Like a pattern or a syntax that you guys
recommend because I've seen a couple of different
ways of doing it.
>> PROBST: Well, hash fragments tend to be
pretty open in what they support. What we
found is that it works pretty well to have
key value pairs just like you would have in
the query parameters. So that's something
that we do recommend and that works.
>> Okay. And how do you separate like the
location from the set of key value parameters
that doesn't--is there--is that part of the
spec or?
>> PROBST: This is--that is not part of the
spec, no.
>> RAMSDALE: Yeah, I think, you're talking
about everything after the hash frag.
>> PROBST: Yeah, yeah.
>> Okay, right. Okay, thanks.
>> RAMSDALE: A good example too is check out
wave, I mean, it's not--this isn't the standard
but I think that they really do a good job.
And you can see how they're saying, "Okay,
I want this wave. I want this minimized. I
want my inbox showing, so on and so forth."
I mean, literally, they have what looks like
the state of the application in that hash
fragment. I think that's a good starting point.
>> Yes, I noticed in Gmail and Wave, they've
done similar things where you have the location,
the slash, and then all the parameters following
it so...
>> Right.
>> I didn't know if there was a standard coming
out or...
>> RYAN: We are going to take a crack at that
that 2.1 release. It's not in the 2.1 snapshot
yet. So don't go look in yet. But we are putting
together an applications framework. That's
what Roo was generating too in the keynote
yesterday. And one of the things that we must
address is at least some kind of standards
for, oh, I've got some state after the hash
fragment; how am I going to turn that into
my upstate?
>> Okay.
>> RYAN: So, I don't know if we'll do it right
yet but we're going to take a stab.
>> Okay, great thanks.
>> Hi, my GWT application backs on to a Spring
and Hibernate back end. And with the new Spring
Roo or with the new GWT and Spring Roo integration,
will I still need to use Gilead, like something
that goes off and fetches my proxied objects?
>> RYAN: I don't know that side of it too
well. Do we still need to use that?
>> Gilead. It ties into the persistence context
and when it...
>> RYAN: Okay. If that's what Roo is setting
you up to use in the screen setup, nothing
has changed on that front. So it's the--the
work has been to get it to generate a Roo
app--sorry, generate a GWT app that talks
to a fairly generic servelet that then talks
to the public API that Roo was generating
already, static finder, methods, and that
kind of thing. I think, under the hood, that's
using the same Spring persistence mechanism
and fetching frameworks that were there already.
>> Okay. Cool, yeah. Excellent. Thanks.
>> We use decorator panels some. Do you have
any plans to come up with a decorated layout
panel?
>> RYAN: The guy that could really answer
that is not here but I could take it. The
decorated panels happened before client bundle
and CSS resource happened. And we haven't
yet integrated that world into our default
where it sat very well. We know that we need
to--I don't think we figured out exactly how
we want to go with that. And I think the decorated
panels in particular--we consciously stay
away from that for the layout panels.
>> YAP: Yes, so if Joel were here, I think
he would say, "Don't decorate the layout panels;
use the layout panels for layout and put things
in the layout panels to do the decoration."
And to go back to client bundle, Raymond,
if you could talk about the pattern--dependence
ejection pattern for passing in a widget's
resources maybe instead of using the decorator
panel pattern.
>> Yeah.
>> YAP: So.
>> RYAN: I don't have much to say beyond that.
We've--we kick it back and forth. So we've
experimented with having the widget declare
the particular CSS resource interface that
it wants as a constructor argument and it's
up to a theme to provide that. We've seen
some libraries internally where they'll actually
declare a decorator interface. Nothing to
do with the decorator panels that we do right
now but an object that is responsive for being
familiar with the DOM structure of the particular
widget and being responsible for adding CSS
styles or putting wrappers around it to make
things go, that kind of a thing. We're still
debating what direction we want to go to with
our own set--our own widgets like that.
>> YAP: So if your intended goal is to theme
a widget or have a widget be themeable, you
can just have that widget take in a client
bundle instance and it's constructor and then
you can--you can control how that gets created.
And you can stub in your own custom styles
so can declare one CSS resource interface
and then you supply different instances of
that. You can point them different CSS files
so you can get the effect of a widget with
a single-style interface basically that you
can theme differently at your whim. So that's
the pattern.
>> So you're moving away from decorator panels?
>> RYAN: It seems like.
>> YAP: Yeah, it seems like it.
>> RYAN: John Benca who--John, could you--John,
can you pick up a microphone, all right, or
shout really loud?
>> BENCA: I work with Joe--I work with Joel.
You might want to take a look at the border
image. It's a--I believe it's in the HTML
5 spec. It's supported by Firefox and Web
kit browsers. And it's what we use in the
expenses app. And, basically, you define an
image that has, you know, a border and then
you can define the offsets for the corners
and it will apply then. That's far superior.
I mean, that's basically the best way to pull
that off. The only problem is it's not supported
in IE so I know Joel is looking at a way--ways
to sort of get it to work on IE but we haven't
really come up with a good solution to that
yet. So it's probably going to involve like
chunking the image in.
>> RYAN: Do you know if that's moving in to
IE 9, John, any idea?
>> BENCA: I wish. I don't know.
>> Hi, I built a management Web app with GWT-Ext
and, for various reasons, it needs to run
for a very long period of time, and it's leaking
memory. So I was wondering if you could point
me to tools or resources to help me detect
those. You know, a val drain for GWT would
be super. Any plans?
>> VAWTER: Where are you leaking memory from?
Is it in the DOM layer or are you--or is your
application just simply suffering from too
much object retention?
>> I'm not sure. I want to find out. It's
sort of...
>> YAP: You can probably talk to Joel Webber.
He has--he's the memory leak expert for browsers.
And he has numerous log posts on exactly what's
going on there. So part of using GWT-Ext is--well,
it's--I don't think they're using GWT users
event, you know, stuff so...
>> VAWTER: Yeah. I don't specifics of the
Ext there. If you--something that you can
do is run your application using development
node and then look at the Java heap because
if it turns out that your problem is too much,
you know, object retention, that will show
up with regular JVM inspection tools. Similarly,
you can do some very rough profiling of, you
know, orders of magnitude comparisons between
this thing and that thing, using the JVM.
But if it turns out that you're, you know,
actually leaking DOM objects due to your UI
bindings and stuff like that, that you're--that
you might hopefully see some...
>> YAP: If you were not--if you are not explicitly
unhooking your event handlers, you will leak
memory so--which is part of the reason why
GWT user widgets have that extra overhead
is that they don't let you leak memory.
>> So, aside from, you know, sort of guessing,
trialing, and so on, any plans for any tools
to make this easier to check?
>> YAP: Yes, okay.
>> AYERS: I was going to say one; in Speed
Tracer, we did have some memory leaks right
before some major release. And it was a big
help for us; we're using Chrome and Chrome
does have some--you can even look at the memory
usage within Chrome. And, basically, we just
start playing around, you know, we broke the
app, we started just knowing out instances
until we found some clues and then went back
and fixed--patched things up. So it's those
little tricks like that. Now, the Chrome Web
inspector is really powerful.
>> YAP: And I don't want to make a promise
but we--we want you to have a heap graph as
well to show the side of your heap before
and after JC runs and during each event, so
you should be able to track your memory usage
that way as well to see if you have a leak.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> I saw a reference to JSR 303 validation
in the bike shed. Is there a serious effort
going on there?
>> RYAN: There is a reference to JSR 303 validation
in bike shed. There's a strong intent. We
haven't gone to that yet. We only just snuck
in any validation at all at the last second
before the keynote demo. My strong hope is
that what will happen is the annotations that
are on your service identities will be reflected
in the DTOs that we generate for you. And
we should be able to have server-side code
that enforces the ones that actually make
sense for us to enforce. I'm not familiar
enough with the 303 spec yet to know if we
can actually do stuff like put them on gather
methods or other arbitrary things rather than
actual fields. So I don't know how much we'll
have to reproduce it versus how much we can
just use it. But that's clearly the way to
go. There's homegrown stuff inside of Google
that wasn't quite general enough for us to
harvest that, of course, at least partially
in that style. Anyway, yes, that's the first
class call for 2.1; no progress to report.
>> MANJHI: We also have the validation going
on the server side for what it is worth.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, two questions; one is I am developing
an application that's pulling in a large amount
of data, patient information, and I was in
the other sessions and kind of getting the
feel for it. And I just want to make sure
I'm clear on this is that are you guys recommending
like if you're doing a large query from the
server that you should use a cell-based instead
of widgets? Is that kind of the best way of
doing it especially when you're, you know,
when you want to type in the command and it
pulls it on? Is that the best method of going
about that, just the cell base instead of
pulling widgets? Because from what I was getting
the sense was that widgets--the more widgets
you add to it, the slower it starts to become
and, you know, more cell-based is, you know,
more faster...
>> RYAN: The--the cell-based widgets, that's
the first that they're taking there. We don't
have anything--there's no cell class or anything
like that in the current versions of GWT.
The 2.1 snapshot shows where we're heading
with that.
>> Right.
>> RYAN: What that advice is about is our
existing widget set, as soon as you want to
do something interesting per row like have
a button to click in every row or something
like that, the most natural thing to do right
now is to make a new widget, a new widget,
a new widget, and you quickly wind up with
hundreds or thousands of widgets for not terribly
many rows of data, and it just doesn't scale.
>> Right.
>> RYAN: So, the data-backed widgets, the
cell-based widgets that we're putting together
for you try to remove that need. They're setting
it up so it is possible to add interaction
and to do bulk rendering without winding up
having all the overhead of a widget for every
spot you want the user to be able to click.
>> Is that--you said that's coming out?
>> RYAN: That's coming out.
>> Okay.
>> RYAN: Right. It's not--it's in the 2.1
snapshot, in pretty good form really but it
will still start changing on you. You know,
it's not completely final yet.
>> Okay.
>> RYAN: You can certainly--in the meantime,
if you can't wait for that, you can certainly
look at what we're doing there. There's no
reason that you can't do similar things yourself.
The code is not that hard.
>> YAP: It's just using a flyweight pattern.
>> Right.
>> YAP: So, instead of having a widget instance
per cell or per UI component within a cell,
you have one object instance that's the flyweight
that knows how to render a cell and then when
the backing table tries to render a cell,
it just gives the flyweight the data it needs
to render itself.
>> Okay.
>> YAP: One object versus...
>> RYAN: One of the most of--one of the coolest
lessons I got from that was when you change
something in that table; rather than trying
to be surgical and just update that little
bit of the table...
>> Right.
>> RYAN: ...it's often faster to just go ahead
and recreate the entire inner HTML string
of the whole table and blast it on there,
like the demo they gave where they're typing
keystroke by keystroke and highlighting cells,
the whole table is being repainted each time.
>> Okay.
>> RYAN: And that's faster; isn't that silly?
>> RAMSDALE: So, actually, they've cut us
off. We're actually out of time. But if you
got--you said you had one more question. If
it's quick, you can...
>> Yes, it's a really quick one. You guys
are from Atlanta and I'm at Atlanta. I didn't
know if you have a meet-up where you all meet
up?
>> RAMSDALE: Oh, we actually meet...
>> I mean, because I would love to kind a
sit down once I get back to Atlanta because,
I mean, I have a lot of questions but they
don't, you know, I would love to kind a sit
down and if you guys met up like once a month
or something like that, you know...
>> RYAN: We'll drink a lot so just hang on...
>> RAMSDALE: Well, no, Ray and Amit and Bob
don't--the rest of us do work in Atlanta and
we actually--so we're trying to get a--or
not even trying; we're actually doing this.
It has pretty been successful. We're getting
a GTUG meet-up in the Google office once a
month.
>> Okay.
>> RAMSDALE: Which would have been about right
now but we're obviously we're all here having
fun. So, look for GTUG-Atlanta. There's a
group that Charlie Collins has started up.
And the next meeting would be at the end of
June. And there's developers from the Atlanta
area plus Googlers that come and hang out.
There has only been two; so if you haven't
heard about that, that's probably why.
>> Okay.
>> RAMSDALE: But look for GTUG Atlanta.
>> I can just Google GTUG Atlanta and it will...
>> RAMSDALE: Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> RAMSDALE: Yup. And there's a mailing list
on top on it and you'll be notified when we
have the next meet-up and please come out.
>> Thank you.
>> RAMSDALE: Yeah, thanks a lot. I appreciate
you for coming out. Everybody, have fun and
let's enjoy standing on the long line for
lunch.